let's go next to our caller from the
three one five area code who's calling
today from three one five oh my on yes
you are who's this
hi I'm still from Billy's foursome
caller I was just thinking about how all
this is going to impact the election and
impact just politics going forward over
the rest of the year and beyond I mean
the the current protesters poses a
pandemic you know I would want to
believe that this is going to really be
a one-two punch to Trump to the
Republicans but I I've been concerned
about a backlash coming and as well as
and I think even if the Republicans are
taken out and Trump's taken out in the
election that they tend to do better as
is an opposition and they tend to do
better campaigning and having something
it has someone to run against and so I
just wonder if any any good can be made
for listen if we can get you have
Democrats and progressives into
positions of power to effect change that
it's not going to lead to kind of
somewhere backlash just like after Obama
and Democrats came in after Bush and so
listen there's a lot of questions in
there let's address at least a couple of
the things you're mentioning first of
all of course Republicans are going to
take whoever is ever in power on the
Democratic side demonize them fundraise
by lying about them come up with the
most horrible allegations and assert of
course of course that's going to happen
if we say well then we'd better not
elect anybody then we're just going to
lose every election so of course they're
going to do it we need to be better at
fighting them rather than ceding the
space and conceding that to them your
first question was could there be a
backlash and Trump rockets to
re-election in November I think the
answer is yes and this is why I've been
urging such caution you know right now
we've got a disastrous economic
situation partially fueled by a
disastrous reaction by Trump to the
pandemic combined with Trump saying hey
let's here's the solution to protest
about police brutality let's send in the
federal military to be even more brutal
like it's crazy Joe Biden is up 11 in
some polls ok I think it is come you're
very right to be skeptical that this is
going to hold through November if the
protests die down it's very unlikely the
protests are going to last five months
if coronavirus continues to decline in a
lot of places I mean it's going up in
some places and it's very much down in
some places but if the economy starts to
appear to be recovering you could get a
window of six weeks in late October into
November where Trump gets himself
reelected because people feel like hey
things are getting back on track and so
I think we need to be very careful about
looking at any of these polls that say
Oh Biden's gonna crush him Biden may
crush Trump Biden may lose and we've got
to be really careful about it right and
obviously I've never been the type of
person that felt like you shouldn't vote
even if your candidate and one of the
primary yeah and also that I do believe
that Trump does have a chance of winning
so again I want I want to believe I'm
not going to let myself be lulled into a
false sense of security but I do want to
believe that he's on his way out I think
I'm just very scarred from cuz I came of
age politically really when Obama during
Obama's first election and that's when I
think my my beliefs
yeah become solidified and I think just
the backlash to him how swift it was I
mean I remember it was around when the
Tea Party first cropped up but it was
between like February April 2009 I mean
if I recall correctly it was very very
soon after he came in and then it was a
two thousand or two thousand ten uh
midterms I just think that that's
something to I mean I'm probably getting
ahead of myself but yeah listen filler
here's what we got to do let's try to
replace Trump with Biden let's try to
take control of the Senate we've got
five six good good races that could be
won
and then okay the the opposition party
tends to win in midterms but maybe this
time they don't and then we fight for
the 2022 midterms we can't win the 2022
midterms this November we can only win
the elections that are this November
this November if that makes sense all
right my friend I'm gonna let you go cuz
I've got a bunch of people who who want
to get on let me take a quick break if
you're holding don't hang up because we
will get right back to the phones
momentarily